(energetic piano music)
- We're gonna try all
these different flavors,
we're gonna guess what they are.
(ringing bell)
(chips rustle)
- Smells like a spice rack.
- Whoa.
- It smells like a deli.
- I don't know how I feel about this.
- It, like, changes flavors.
- Mm-hmm.
- Kind of, right?
- They really nailed the
rye and sauerkraut flavor.
- Yeah.
- Tastes like cheese, there's
like this big cheese--
- Sour cheese.
- It does taste like a Reuben.
(chips rustle)
- These chips are big
first of all, that's great.
- Oh, man. That smells like...
- Fish.
- That doesn't taste like anything.
- Reminds me of an Italian restaurant.
- Yeah it tastes like
an Italian restaurant.
Tastes like pasta chips.
- Do we have to, can we
just stop right here?
I'm done. This is it.
(laughs)
- We're gonna finish out the
bowl and we'll be right back.
(chips rustle)
- Wow these are brown.
- These look like it's gonna
be a really strong flavor.
- Yeah.
- Oh!
- Is this chip like thicker to you?
And like harder?
- Mm-hm.
- It tastes kinda like a salad to me.
- There's like, olive.
- There's like a pickle element of it.
- That's so good, though.
- Almost too much for a chip.
(chips rustle)
- They all smell the same, what the,
I'm like mad now.
- Ranch
- Meat
- Ranch?
(laughs)
- I went with meat.
- They taste like upper-class
sour cream and onion.
- Yeah.
- Chips.
- It tastes like grabbing
a handful of meat
and putting it in your mouth.
- Definitely a hint of gravy.
- Is that pepper?
- Yeah, there's definitely pepper on it.
- There's something comforting about them.
- Yeah.
- A little homey.
- I think we both agree that
these are truffle, right?
- Oh yeah.
- I thought this would be easy
and it's actually really difficult.
- Definitely the biscuits and gravy here.
- We're right!
(bell rings)
- Woot woot.
- This is our guess.
(bell rings)
- Nice.
(buzzer sounds)
- Are you kidding me?
- No!
- What?!
- - Not a chance in hell!
(bell rings)
- Yeah!
- You're telling me that
this is how it should go.
- I'm gonna stare at this one and eat.
- God damn it, you're right.
- I think this might be my
favorite, the biscuits and gravy.
- Nah, man.
- Baby, no, wrong.
- It's all about that Reuben.
- Your choice is wrong.
- I think it's pretty apparent
which one's a favorite.
- I feel like we live in the future,
and that you can eat a
sandwich in chip form.
- Oh! I wish Lays would
just make bags of meat.
(laughs)
That tasted like other things.
Like instead of, leave
the potato behind, Lays!
Just give us roast beef
that tastes like chicken.
How fun!